and now it's music time again in Santa
Monica to present the Oscars for Best
music scored there is a married couple
who's racked up a pretty good score
themselves mr. Tony Martin and his own
el Cyd Charisse
well darling you start huh for that
scoring of a musical picture the
nominees are
George Bruns for Babes in Toyland Alfred
Newman and Ken Dhabi for Flower Drum
Song
Dmitri Shostakovich for Kevon Sheila do
Gallatin for Paris blues saw chaplain
Johnny green Sid Raymond and Ervin costo
for West Side Story
may we have the album Oh the winners are
Saul chaplain Johnny
looking for soul chaplain mr. Johnny
green dear members of the Academy may I
present my distinguished colleague CID
Raymond I'm overwhelmed and I thank the
members of the Academy and mr. Bernstein
mr. Sondheim the wonderful music and I'm
just thankful for the award great thank
you and Irwin Costa ladies and gentlemen
Thank You Johnny
well Sid has said it all thank you ever
so much
Thank You Johnny good ladies and
gentlemen on behalf of our absolute
colleague and devoted friend Saul
Chaplin great thanks from all of us
and Tony yeah before you read the next
nominees I noticed the memorandum in the
script and what's it say so
memo to dick green and how panda
scriptwriters because the orchestra will
need a little extra time to set the
music between the musical scoring and
the dramatic harmony scoring Awards
will you please provide Sid and Tony
with some extra lines of dialogue
anything will fill signed Johnny green
and where's the dialogue the nominees
for best music score of a dramatic a
comedy picture of Henry Mancini for
breakfast at tiffany's Nicholas Rocha
for El Cid Morris stole off and Harry
Suppan for Fanning
Demetri T um conform ever own Elmer
Bernstein for summer and smoke and the
winner said
the way Henry Mancini
I'm deeply grateful to the members of
the Academy to my good friend Blake
Edwards thank you